Today I want to tell you about what's currently my
favourite number. So my favourite number changes a
lot but for now it is 288. You might be looking
at that and thinking, what's special about 288?
Don't worry we'll get there, but first we
need to rewind a bit and talk a bit about
factorials - specifically super factorials. Now
I know regular Numberphile viewers will have seen
factorials before but super factorials might
be a bit new. But let's start from the basics:
so factorial we'll write n factorial and it's the
product of n- so n times (n - 1) times... and so
on times 2 times 1. So it's the product of n
and all the integers less than n. So that's
the factorial, but there are other things we can
do with factorials as well. So there's something
called a double factorial and what we do here is
rather than multiplying everything we multiply
every other term. So it'll be n and then this time
instead it's n take 2 time n take 4 times dot dot
dot. And now what we end up with will depend
on whether n's odd or even; cos if n is even
then we'll have times 4 times 2 and if n is odd
it will be times 3 times 1 at the end. So that's
double factorial; but I said super factorial. So
what's that? Well the definition I'm going to use
different - mathematicians use super factorial to
mean different things - but I'm going to say that
n super factorial, which is written like this is,
rather than being n times n take 1 times and so
on; n factorial times n take 1 factorial times dot
dot dot times 2 factorial times 1 factorial. Okay.
I'm going to write out some of the factorials
here, so 1 factorial, 1 times 1 is 1. 2 factorial
well that's 2 times 1 is 2. 3 factorial is going
to be 3 times 2 times 1, is 6. 4 factorial is 24, 5
factorial is 120 and so on. Now for the super
factorials, 1 super factorial is just 1
factorial so that's 1. 2 super factorial is
then 1 times 2 which is 2. 3 super factorial is
6 times 2 times 1, so that's 12. 4 super factorial:
24 times 6 times 2 times 1 - and as I'm sure you'll
all have got just as quickly is 288. And 5 super
factorial is this times 120 which I believe is
34,560. So these are some values of super factorials.
Now I also just want to pause, side note, the super
factorial notation I think it's boring. We have
like exclamation marks for factorials and we've just
got the letter sf - so I want to propose a few
changes. Now some people do write it as a dollar
sign, so they'll write five $ sign. I don't like
this though, because you never put a dollar sign
after the number, it just feels feels wrong. So so
I have two different suggestions: firstly we could
continue the exclamation mark theme and use my
favorite puncturation mark which is the interabang,
so that's a question mark and an exclamation mark.
And it's used for rhetorical questions. If you look
at Wikipedia the examples it gives are 'You call
that a hat‽' or my favorite 'What are those‽'. So that's
the interabang or I think we fully embrace the
superness and possibly breach some copyright
rules and just go for super factorial like this.
Um so these are my suggestions, if you have any
better suggestions of how we should denote
super factorial then let me know. The problem
we often have in math is we've exhausted all of
the standard alphabet, we've exhausted all the
Greek alphabet - we're running out of letters and
symbols um. And especially for something like super
factorial that isn't used as commonly um to an
extent as long as I clearly define what I mean by
the symbols you can do what you like. The problem
comes in when I've maybe not said what this symbol
means, but if I'm very clear from the start that
this mean super factorial then we're fine. Um so
what can we do with the super factorials? Before
we move on to my favorite number - which some of you
might have spot us elsewhere on a paper but we're
going to hold our horses there. Well the cool thing
is that for example if we look at for some number
k, 4k super factorial, take that and we divide it by
2k factorial we always get a square number. Which
I don't think is obvious but we can we can show it.
Cos let's look at this 4k super factorial, that's
going to be 4k factorial times 4k - 1 factorial
times 4k - 2 factorial times 4k - 3 factorial times...
and so on times 2 factorial times 1 factorial. And
we can pair these up. So looking at this pair,
we have 4k times 4k - 1 factorial times 4k - 1
factorial so we' we've got 4k - 1 factorial squaredhere.
And then here okay we've got times 4k - 2
times 4k - 3 factorial squared and so on times
2 times 1 factorial squared. So what we get in
total is well 4k - 1 factorial squared times 4k -3 factorial
squared times dot dot dot times 1 factorial
squared. So that's all these pairs; and then times
4k times 4k - 2 times and so on times 2. Now,
eagle eyes amongst you will tell me that that is 4k double
factorial going back to here - and it is - but I want
to leave it like this and actually here we've got
2k terms and they're all even. So we can take out
our factor of 2 - I'm just going to draw a square
to show that this is a square number - times well
2 times 2k times 2 times 2k - 1 times dot dot dot
times 2 times 1. So this bit is going to be our
square number time well 2 to the 2k times 2k factorial.
And now originally we're looking at this divided
by 2k factorial. So our little 4k super factorial
divided by 2k factorial gives us a square number
times 2 to the 2K, which is going to be a square number
because you've got a power of 2. So it works! A
seemingly nonobvious fact can can be shown. Okay,
now I am going to put you out your misery and go
back to number 288; because looking at these if I
just had to glance at them I would say that one
looks the coolest. We've got 3, 4, 5, 6, 0 but that's
not my favorite number - this one is. And it's due to
one other property of it. Because not only
is 288 4 factorial times 3 factorial times 2
factorial times 1 factorial; it is also 4 to power of 4 +
3 to the power of 3 + 2 to the power of 2 plus 1 to the power of 1. And I just
think that's really cool. It's the only number
that this happens for, and we can kind of show
this if you want to get all technical - n factorial
roughly is the square root of (2 pi*n) (n over e to the n). So
you can think multiplying n factorials together
is going to look a bit like multiplying n to the
n together and here we're adding n to the n. So
this is obviously- these are going to grow faster
than doing something like this but anyway we
don't really need to look too much about that. We
just need to look at the number 288 and appreciate
this is really cool. So that's why it's my favourite number
This is halfsies, devised by the
clever folk at Brilliant, it's free to play right
now over on their site. And I absolutely love
it. The idea is to move one piece around until
the shaded and non-shaded areas are exactly
the same size. It's a fun test of your visual
estimation skills - how good are you at this? And
after a simple start you can see things start
getting a little bit tricky! As an Australian
who spends some time in America I particularly
like this one. Head over to Brilliant to give
it a try; the address is written there on the
screen, there's also a link in the video
description. And when you finish you might
be tempted to check out their other countless
courses and quizzes and puzzles - they cover all
matter of science and mathematics. It's a great
place to give your brain a workout. They have a
free 30-day trial and Numberphile viewers
can get a 20% discount on a subscription
by going to brilliant.org/numberphile. Again on
the screen there. Halfsies? Well you can go and
play that for free right now and let me know
your score, leave a comment down in the video description.
I think that's a pretty good guess
for the minimum length of the super permutation
using 1 to 6. Unfortunately recently
someone found a super permutation
that is shorter. In fact they found a super
permutation that had length 872 - one shorter.